I enjoyed Israel a lot you know I went
to the arm we got to cut in line you
know they're just like hey don't worry
about these yeah like cuz we were out
there like we will get a chaperon we had
we were like he be having dinner with
like mayors and governors of like
districts and stuff and so we went to
see so we were like come we're doing
this tour and then we were in this room
and a little cigarette yeah and I was
smoking this and they go don't smoke
here I go why this is where the 12
Supper they had that last supper oh oh
they just they know let me ask you
something how do they know that that's
the place I don't know where were you
do you have you heard of it I've never
been that yeah yeah it was somewhere in
Israel we're in a room think this is
where they had the last supper y'all
smoke yeah I'm like how do you know that
I was like I know that there's there's a
lot of like Jesus places there yeah
they're like we went where they did that
were they lynched him how do you call it
they got him they got him where they got
another five and then I remember when so
they had the slat would they the slab
where they had Jesus's body they had the
Jesus slab they had a slab there and I
remember Steve burn and Bessie burn the
comic was on his hands and knees
touching the slab crying and I never
laughed hard I went into a capital that
no one's ever out of my mind and I took
photos of him crying he offended yes
everybody in line was ahead everyone
there were people yeah if there's a line
that's eight hours long just don't ever
slam a trick they took you to the Jesus
spots and they take you to the Jew spots
no they didn't take you to the western
wall or anything yeah they did that yeah
that's that's the Jew spot I love that
spot but the little they got the little
notes in the wall I didn't know like I
didn't know true with a little note I
got sure I want to get on a network Dave
yeah yeah yeah and then we went into
that's big of you to wish for thank you
thank you that was a very bold selfless
wish yeah yeah
sometimes I honest yes it is brave to
wish for yourself because you always
have this compelling like honey to wish
for the other word but sometimes you got
to wish for yourself I always wish for
myself good for you in fact I don't
think he's ever wished for anybody but
you know why do you know why I don't
wish I do I do for other people right I
put that in action right I wish for
myself [ __ ] notes
I don't do notes for other people but I
get into action
yeah all right we have a little [ __ ]
what is that a sponsor what is it for
Sparkle hood Brooklyn and sparkle
[Music]